[Music]
he can confirm miles teller was involved
in a serious car accident just days
before Christmas according to the LAPD
the whiplash star was driving in Studio
City California Thursday night when he
got cut off by another vehicle
reportedly causing tellers ford bronco
to flip over the actors truck was towed
away from the scene but he and the
passenger in his vehicle walked away
uninjured it didn't really cause me too
much unrest the two passengers in the
car that cut off tellers were
transported to the hospital for minor
injuries interestingly enough miles has
starred in both whiplash and bleed for
this where his character was involved in
near fatal car crashes I've got to stop
seeing him in car crashes it's starting
to like freak me out okay and imagine
what it's like for you yeah acting in
them all the time I guess I was very
nervous even though I told the director
yak you know I'm your guy let me do this
there's a big part of me that was like
I'll even know if I can get in that kind
of shape
[Music]
you